welcome to episode 21 of the michaela
peterson podcast
and episode one of me actually speaking
to someone live in person
it was so fun in this episode i got to
chat with nicole arbour
i asked her to come on the podcast a
while ago and a few weeks back
she commented on a photo on instagram
and suggested we get coffee
i said bourbon i don't drink coffee she
said how about a bourbon and a podcast
two birds one stone so this podcast
episode
is somewhat bourbon soaked be prepared
nicole arper is a fellow canadian who
lives in toronto and la
she's an actress comedian youtuber
former cheerleader for the toronto
raptors
and she's incredibly smart she also
works as a tech and social media
entrepreneur
and ceo coach i wanted to speak with her
because she recovered from being
horribly injured
and she has an amazing sense of humor
hopefully some of that humor comes
through in this episode
we spoke about her injury volunteering
with scientologists
speaking too fast for your significant
other to understand
personality differences between people
from los angeles and
canada and where to turn to when
conventional medicine fails and a lot
more
i hope you enjoyed this episode i
certainly did shout out to murty
creative company for sponsoring this
episode
about a year ago colin murty sent me an
absolutely gorgeous leather journal
that i use at night to spill all my
thoughts onto to avoid using my phone
before bed
there's really something to writing and
writing by hand is therapeutic i find
particularly in times like we're all
experiencing now or times of stress
if you need a gift for someone a
leather-bound journal is something i
think most people would appreciate
and to make it even sweeter for my
listeners colin murty
is offering free personalization on any
of their products
to redeem go to murtycreative.co that's
m-u-r-d-y-creative.co
and use michaela on the cart page for
free name personalization on any of
their products
and that's m-i-k-h-a-i-l-a on the cart
page for free name personalization
for really beautiful leather binders
journals and folios
check out marty creative.co and if
you're a fan of podcasts
go check out their podcast
murtycreative.co podcast where their
founder colin murty talks about the
challenges and triumphs of starting a
small business
so just search mardi creative.co on
youtube
or your favorite podcast app to learn
more so thank you
merty creative co and i do really
appreciate
the journal so enjoy the episode
[Music]
so
[Music]
nicole arbour welcome to my podcast
holla
i'm so excited to be here and drinking
bourbon with you i'm so excited
we're drinking bourbon we're drinking
bourbon and soda water
bad ass [ __ ] yeah you suggested
coffee but i don't drink coffee
i like this about you even more i feel
like we're instant friends now
like like kind of right like we were
we're internet friends now we're real
life friends
yeah well everyone's kind of an internet
friend like nowadays right
the whole coronavirus thing or internet
enemies
true i was gonna say like i don't like
some people
like let's be realistic we'd be liars to
be like everyone's my friend sunshine
and rainbows buy my book
oh my god yes actually like twitter
jesus uh okay okay before we get into
twitter later before we get started
can you give like a very brief
background about who you are
to anybody listening that doesn't know
who you are yeah uh
hi humans i'm nicole arbour i'm a
comedian
and uh background wise i'm from canada
born and raised in the hamilton holler
uh i have to do that i think after just
for my street
after talking about hamilton yeah for my
street i'm just like toronto snob here
yeah hamilton gross we have to like
smoke cigarettes to breathe that's like
the joke
breathe fresh air um yeah and i started
like
doing stand up and stuff since i was 18
was one of those like star searching
kind of kids
and was crushing it i was on the whole
much music thing for years hosting giant
concerts working with huge brands like
nike and virgin moba writing their ad
campaigns
and then it was like a boom car accident
after a show one night and then spent
most of my 20s
in bed on disability with ridiculous
chronic pain
all sorts of the chronic pain that i'm
sure will probably get into some of it
and it wasn't until i decided that i was
getting better
after i got the disability certificate
from the government and i was approved
for life for disability
that i said oh hell no and made all the
changes in my own life
and took myself off disability in 2015
march and then by september i was the
most viral comedian in history
and then by a couple months later i was
at the oscars so it kind of went from
there
got over a billion organic views which
is dope
and now i'm working with brands uh
tons of brands tons of people other
influencers i work in tech i consult for
everyone on their tech for like facebook
and youtube and
i've hacked most of them and i'm having
a good time
yeah okay um let's because i want to
have fun we're drinking bourbon i like
having fun yeah i like having fun too
but i do want to get into the health
problems you had and how you got out of
them yeah
a big portion of my audience has i think
if you can measure audience i think are
suffering from chronic disease
and it's brutal and i think people who
haven't experienced
some sort of illness just don't get how
horrible it can be
yep uh and they and they're i do feel
like there are steps you can take to
escape that that you're not told because
a lot of the times you go to the doctor
and they're like yeah
you're stuck yeah pills you're stuck
like this for life like it's
we don't know why but like i think that
should be illegal by the way i think it
should be illegal for a doctor
to say you're going to be like this
forever i think yeah i think it messes
up
your society so you stop looking right
because you're like well there
they have the experience they know what
they're talking about if i'm stuck like
this i'm stuck like this and it takes
some of the responsibility off of your
shoulders
yeah yeah that's complete [ __ ] i
think it should be illegal
because if i go back to all the doctors
who told me i wouldn't get better
i would have never gotten better if i if
i listened to them
and i had one doctor actually at the
chronic pain clinic
in toronto um well i forgot what it's
called
rothbart chronic pain center that was
the first doctor
who said that i could get better and
he's like will you do everything i tell
you to do
and i was like yeah like if you're
saying i have a way out
yeah and he said i want you to look into
that waiting room
and he's like those people will never
get better because they don't believe
they're ever gonna get better
and then they're done they come here
weird right but he's right
he was right and he's like a younger fit
good-looking guy who believes just as
much
in the medicine of it as he does the
natural side of it and that it's an
active getting better especially from
chronic injuries pain
disease is an active participant sport
it's not a
sit there and watch it you can't get
better from doing nothing
so he gave me a bunch of steps that
included my
diet that we can jump into all of it
because i know you're big into the diet
diet what i'm doing i stopped watching
the news i only took in positivity
because it raises your anxiety levels
you're [ __ ] up your own vibe
we can get into the quantum physics of
it but i followed all of it
to a t i did not cheat and then i went
from
being able to do a couple steps to a
couple more steps
an eventual jog and yeah i'm skipping
obviously a lot of the middle right now
yeah but i just needed that one doctor
to tell me that i could she said it
changed like
yeah i didn't know yeah i had okay okay
let's start
let's back let's back up a little bit
back back back it down
what happened um i was getting a taxi
and i just finished a show i was gonna
go do some karaoke with a buddy
get a little backstreet boys going and
uh
yeah i was opening the taxi door and we
got rear ended as i was halfway out
oh my god it's like every time i think
about it like i clench
like my butt cheeks clench because it's
just the way that i was twisted
my head hit the inside of the door frame
three times and
like the neck injuries that go with that
too because like a whiplash is like a
and so that's three head hits and then
the neck injuries right away because my
spine was twisted
it jabbed into my nerves down my spine
like my own spine injured me basically
and
my hips like my si joint ended up out of
place and my hips were out of alignment
my one leg is
visibly longer than the other one it's a
talent now
uh party track i can kick higher here
and
uh yeah so basically that's what
happened we got hit there when i was
halfway out
and it ended up in being like tmj
that was so bad i was crushing my own
teeth in my sleep and waking up without
teeth
uh i'd swallow them uh it was so bad i
couldn't put a spoon in my mouth to eat
when i got to tmj i got so skinny like
there's photos of me even a couple years
ago i look emaciated like i just look
emaciated and people thought i was
dieting i couldn't eat
because i couldn't chew so they went
from head injury as well which was
that was probably the hardest part when
i think of it other than the physical
pain
is not remembering my address
being somewhere and forgetting how i got
there
getting into the shower and knowing
something feels off
but i don't know what and i was fully
clothed in the shower
and i didn't know like i couldn't put
those two and two together i'd put my
keys in the fridge
there's all these weird little cognitive
things that were going on
and then getting over that and then
having to deal with the physical pain
because i would
shake like i had parkinson's for most of
the day i'd be sweating through my
sheets every night
uh multiple times a night like i'd have
to change my sheets in the night
okay go on so part of the reason
i wanted to talk to you and i don't like
i'm very careful about comparing my
situation with
other people's situations especially
when they're like severe and yours
sounds
like it was severe it's all relative
it's all good a lot of the
symptoms you had i had and i didn't get
it like i didn't have an accident i had
a
really severe autoimmune disorder but i
had the same like sweating at night
it was like i'd wear pajamas to like
having a relationship was
like like try cuddling like yeah yeah i
feel you it was not pretty like that's
not cute
right you know how someone dated me
through that but yeah either like you're
married and have a hot kid
well not hot i shouldn't say hot what am
i netflix like like
no cute i don't mean hot yeah um but i
did this like like i wore pajamas to bed
and i slept on a towel and i'd wake up
at two in the morning and take off my
pajamas because they were soaked yep and
then i'd wake up at like six in the
morning
and take off my towel because i'd soak
through it yeah so it's just it's
weird and some of these cognitive things
like i mine were bad
but they weren't like get in the shower
with clothes on bad they were bad like i
couldn't remember anything
like i couldn't like that brain fog that
was so thick it was so bad that i
couldn't remember anything but it wasn't
like keys in fridge yes shower with
clothes on no
not like quite there yeah and then the
chronic pain i can identify with
as well so anyway you had a [ __ ] time
and you had
years right many a year yeah it was
i would say the better part of seven
years was
extremely bad while trying to hide it
which
yeah yeah you know trying to hide it and
still work and do whatever i could which
was
barely nothing so yeah better part of
seven years yeah
yeah but also what like for people who
are in that situation and
who are living in like chronic pain or
with chronic disease
if you don't think you can get out of it
then you don't have really any other
option then just be like yeah i'm okay
because what are you going to do like
just cry
all the time like it doesn't do anything
but make you
look ugly and really how you get like
puffier yeah
and mentally exhausted and yeah uh
okay so you met this doctor
and he was like hey you actually have an
option here
and so what did he suggest and how did
you crawl your way out of that
nerve block injections that's one of the
active things he was doing
uh i feel like they saved me life
i really do because for nerve block
injections we did them
in my skull like into the nerves in
there have you done them before no i
haven't they're [ __ ] painful i didn't
have i didn't have nerves
oh no nerve stuff okay yeah yours was
awesome mine is like bone
okay so they basically take uh
if they're a nice doctor they take the
long skinny japanese needles
this is gonna be screenshotted for sure
just just saying
cool i'm gonna do this just in case uh
yeah so they take the needles
and it's like a local anesthetic that
they would give you at the dentist like
lidocaine
yep but they're sticking it to your
nerves uh trigger points throughout your
body and that lasts
three months up to three months
depending on how fast you process it
and they do it in here for me they did
it like down my neck to
jaw trigger points through here uh in
here
down my spine s i joints i don't
wish it on anybody like it's a lot of
[ __ ] pain like you think getting a
needle hurts get it into your nerves you
know what i mean i
i did have one okay i had one because
i've had i had an ankle replacement
installed improperly
what yeah so i had 10 years of a crooked
ankle replacement which i would not
recommend
walked a little funky oh my god yeah i
should only wear heels and then
it was like it was a little funky i'm a
little skinnier on the left side but
like
it sorted itself out now but i did get a
nerve block above
just like in the back of my knee how was
that
it worked yay yeah it's fine like it's
the problem is solved now but do you
still get them no
not that often like ah okay so you
managed to heal
yeah so that was step one of healing was
i needed
my body to calm down long enough for me
to start sleeping yeah
jesus and then yeah yeah after you can
sleep because my my nerves weren't like
twitching as much uh
they also made me smoke weed and i had
never been
i know it sounds like so silly now but
like i had never been into smoking weed
ever i feel like it's a personality
thing too like some people get more
if i smoke weed i like forget how to
speak to people
that's why sometimes when i go on
podcasts like comedy podcasts they're
like yeah let's smoke first i'm like no
let's not yeah right
i close your brain some people speeds
their brain up depends on the kind of
weed
is what i've learned i had to like
connoisseur eventually that's true
but they forced me they're like listen
[ __ ] like they actually said that
they're like listen [ __ ]
if you don't smoke a little bit and this
was the toronto pain clinic yep
yep yep rothbart center
so i don't know if he's there anymore
it's i could look him up
but uh it was the rothbart pain center
that they had this
full idea of treatment for me and i had
to smoke a little bit
so i would stop shaking and then
it and it worked instantly every single
time and then
after that i had the nerve blocks i
could start to like walk and build
muscle again
and with the nerve blocks in here i
could open my mouth and start eating
again
uh i had sticky notes all over my entire
house
that i put things like you look great
today
you are getting healthier every day
you're awesome
this was just for a period of time like
you can walk
what made you decide what made you
decide to start writing those
a louise hay book yeah like hey house
she's good she's so good she's uh
i'd say she's one of like the actual
positivity pioneers
and it came from a lot of psychology
but it was that trigger of i'm not
taking in
anything but positivity at least until i
start to heal and it changed my whole
life
like i think that thing was so big
and i wouldn't watch the news like i
said i used to love csi i cut out csi
i don't need to see people suffering
yeah i don't need to hear those noises
uh my ex-boyfriend used to watch what's
it called what's the zombie one
walking dead where it's just like
screaming and blood yeah all the time
nope it's just like all i did was watch
i swear to god in my worst period of
time like i was just like hannibal i was
like on 40 milligrams of adderall and i
was like
hannibal but you right that's what you
want like when you're in pain well also
if you're like
oh if your body is already wired as if
you're
like being traumatized then at least
when you're watching some of those shows
it's like
now there's a reason that i don't just
like feel like this walking around i
think that was part of the reason
that makes so much sense i think yeah
same like because i got into
a whole bunch of different tv series
that were all like traumatic and
violent and whatever stressful yeah
stressful but when i cut them out
i started to heal and my body
stopped doing this constantly and
the triggers of a steady stream of
positivity
and motivation and i like i'm a pretty
spiritual person too i was binging on
like
three to five podcasts or
sermons a day as well like christian
buddhist i don't give a [ __ ] i'm getting
it in here
let's learn positive stuff whatever
works anything all of it i wanted all of
it
and it started working and i really
think that
plus the physical stuff and i did a
really strict alkaline diet
and i did not deviate from it some
people say it's [ __ ]
worked for me so whatever you want i
don't eat gluten dairy soy
okay gluten dairy and soy yep that's
like when i first started i made it like
a diet blog
because i was having these weird food
reactions and
like everyone including myself thought i
was insane i was like
i cannot have like this is too much
these reactions are too much like i had
i tried to reintroduce soy bacon and i
hallucinated and i was like that is
that is crazy no but i believe it yeah
yeah so it's bad so and
on my blog it's like if you if you only
have to cut out
three things yep gluten dairy soy yep
which gets me in trouble because
i've had i've been in a like in a car
like an uber and the uber driver is
telling me about how his son
lives with his mom and she wants to put
him on add drugs and i'm like what are
his symptoms
and he told me and i was like take my
phone number
this sounds like an allergy and it was
and the mom was like fighting to put
this little kid a four-year-old on drugs
oh my god i idiot that's like
well yeah yeah whatever there's a place
for a certain amount of time but i'm
just
yeah yeah they wanted me drugged up and
when i got off the drugs is when i
started feeling better
and doing all the natural things and
actually participating i know
i i had the same i was um
i was on a ton of things and i cannot i
also understand why i was put on them
because i was
so ill like i couldn't function at all
um but i was on like immune suppressants
and when i was in chronic pain it wasn't
like gabapentin they tried to give me a
cannabis derivative
this was when i was at sick kids though
so okay they gave me like a number of
medications that didn't really work but
i've been i've been through the drug
route and the problem with drugs
and i've been through like all of them
and i feel like you've probably been
through most of them but i've also been
through like the psych side
like same okay i hallucinated like
crazy like i've told they made me
suicidal and i had never been suicidal
and i wasn't suicidal for the pain
which ones uh top of mex sprinkle was
specific i do not know what that is i
have not
i know i know most of them that one what
is it that one i believe
is supposed to be an anti-seizure
medication but i was given it by the
head injury clinic yeah because of the
severity of whatever the head injuries
and stuff
which turns out sped me up cognitively
um
the head injury they tested me no way
are you sure it wasn't the diet change
yeah because it was before that oh yeah
that's we could talk about that because
that's like that's a twist it's a
i i'm a concussion collector or i have
been i'm done now
thank you uh yeah i'm at like five
really i've sped up each time i met
stay there i had a seat i had a seizure
after one of them yeah stay there two
seizures yeah why did you have a seizure
i climbed up this was after my so i had
my hip and ankle replaced when i was 17.
okay and i didn't do anything for a
[ __ ] year i was on oxycontin
like enough i was on so much oxycontin
because either i would have like i was
i was in so much pain i couldn't sleep
and if you're in so much pain you can't
sleep in your school
yeah because you can't sleep exactly so
i was in that much pain so i was put on
opiates
thank god because i couldn't get my hip
ankle replaced fast enough because we're
in [ __ ] canada and i don't want to
talk about the healthcare system here
really but like
so i couldn't do it fast enough so i was
on opiates anyway it was a year of that
and i finally i had the surgeries i got
off of everything and then i was like
yes i'm like free i've got my joints
back and so i climbed this
giant yeah that's exactly like straight
up
yeah for sure and i wasn't like that
young i was 18
but i was with one of my friends and we
were supposed to be studying for math
exam and i was like i'm just gonna like
i bet you can't climb the statue he was
doing parkour parkour
hardcore parkour yeah and i was like
yeah but you can't like climb that he's
like i'm not climbing that's [ __ ]
stupid and i was like fine i'll do it um
no
yes i climbed up it was totally fine and
then
on the way down i slipped and fell into
concrete and smacked my head
he didn't stick the dismount threw up
all the sour keys i'd eaten for
breakfast and
oh getting a seizure on the way to the
hospital oh
oh my gosh i know point oh it wasn't
that
like it wasn't that it didn't
hurt i don't know why hearing about
somebody else getting a concussion kind
of makes me laugh but it kind of does
because i'm like oh we get them so
stupid
humans are so stupid really stupid i
called my dad so i landed on the ground
and called my dad and was like
uh so i'm just gonna like i'm just gonna
go to the hospital because i fell but
i'm okay i'm just gonna get checked out
and then like i'll be home after school
my dad was like writing he's like yeah
okay okay that sounds good
right and so i go to the hospital with
my friend have a seizure in the
ambulance on the way to the hospital i'm
in this like brace
yeah and my mom comes home and is like
where's michaela and my dad's like she's
at the hospital but she's okay and then
he's like wait
that's such a dude that like my mom was
like okay and went to the hospital but
it was okay how do you manage to get
five that's like that's
like that's a lot why i'm laughing is
because i'm like ah you have a stupid
story too
yeah stupid things okay the concussion
counter okay the first one was
playing king of the castle when i was a
little kid okay snow hill
i made it to the top another boy was mad
i was the top tried to pull me down
welcome to being a woman in
entertainment [ __ ] um
yeah so he pulled me and i hit my head
another one was like
dancing doing like an acro class i was
just trying a new trick
landed on my head is what it is car
accident
car accident and then a police officer
that was not in a uniform one time
picked me up and threw me against a wall
because he was trying to get to a fight
trying to save some people yeah but that
had ended an hour ago
so yeah that was a thing wow yeah
there's there's my like uh random blm
story is they told me that if i reported
it
that they would say i was drunk and
tried to hit an officer
no straight up that happened and i was
like
i was the designated driver and everyone
backed me up including the owner of the
bar
so they told the bar owner that if you
backed me up they'd close this bar
they'd say that like there was a liquor
license there what yeah isn't that crazy
is that in canada yes it was unionville
ontario
yeah wow there's our stories
so yeah concussion collects yeah yeah
and they
they're weird they're very strange i
didn't i don't know i was on so much
medication at the time i i didn't even
notice much except my neck cracked
afterwards
that was that was basically it though if
you're listening if you get a concussion
if you think you have a concussion you
need to go get
acupuncture into your neck as soon as
possible
that is what saved me in the last one
and
i was so lucky that i was treated i was
like rushed in and treated by the same
doctor that treats
the nhl players and a lot of the nfl
players that get back with
acupuncture he said acupuncture right
now really
called someone to do it for me and it's
to make sure that that blood flow keeps
going
and i was so foggy and i could feel like
a bad concussion coming
oh yeah and then afterwards it was just
as they were doing it really yeah and i
had to do it four days in a row
in my neck it's not very long yeah
really for
healing from a concussion well i wasn't
healed but like that's yeah yeah yeah
for that part
stopping these stops like the swelling
or something it stops your brain from
swelling yeah
so if you get a concussion stick needles
in your neck
not personally go to a professional yeah
yeah
interesting these are the things cool
wow we're all over the place
we are uh okay so
you did these nerve blocks and then
you're able to
move more get so much sleep which is
seriously
important for recovery yep um
you're able to move more and you changed
your diet yeah
you did an alkaline diet which i'm not
like i don't
i'm on an all-meat diet right so i can't
say like anything about anything because
fair you said no that is fair because
yeah literally i was one of those people
when i was like 21 that was like
gluten-free whatever and then i ended up
having celiac disease and was like oh
do i have celiac disease because of the
amount of time i spent making fun of
gluten-free people maybe
i don't know maybe karma yeah maybe yeah
so so then there was that and then i was
on a paleo diet and it helped a lot and
then i was on
you know i and then i went to like meat
and greens because i was just getting
it wasn't enough meat and greens and
then i went to meat and it like
solved all my problems and i was like
well you're pretty much just a texan
yeah it's like true yeah no one's gonna
take this seriously so i don't like
write off any of these diets but there
are patterns among a lot of the diets
that seem to work for people
and a lot of them cut grains processed
foods sugar
um legumes particularly soy
soy people underestimate story and it's
in everything if i have like the tiniest
bit of soy
yeah i feel it instantly i know if there
was soy in a margarine
in a baked good that was gluten-free
yeah i feel it yeah i i had a reaction
from soy and fillers
like just soy lecithin oh my gosh
that's probably what happened to me last
year this is like a cautionary tale
i had a jaw surgery to like fixing up
the things still and they put in a
filler to just like
even me out after and my whole face went
like
and it was exploded my ears were ringing
for months they thought i had cancer
what did they use um it was
it's like one of the normal fillers but
apparently it's a cheap one and it had
it says right on it that it's not for
celiacs and
gluten in a filler they put gluten and
filler yeah
i i wish i could remember the name of it
it's it's like terrifying
it's one of like the juvederms or
something like that really celiacs can't
have it
they can't have it and the goddess
didn't check my chart so
he just was like i'm helping her out i'm
evening out the filler
and for three four months i literally
thought i had cancer or something
so yeah that's fine be careful of the
fillers what filler did you have
so that i know filler where look like
you had filler in a food oh no filler
and pills
they're talking about lip filler like i
don't know i had jaw filler gluten
but is that like near the bone yeah
yeah but it's like probably the same as
like a lip filler or something
it's like a skin terrifying it was i
blew up
well that's good to know yeah don't do
that if things start to like
sag or beg or you want to just tweak
things up make sure you're using
some good stuff yeah i've noticed like
throughout the whole diet experience
because i was super paranoid when i
first got better it was like when you
get better you're like
how do i keep this like let's not delve
like
dive back into the hell i was in yeah
and so i was like
i will filter all my water i wasn't
using any products on my skin because i
didn't
know like is it something i'm ingesting
or is it something that's like topical
like how sensitive
am i yeah and it turns out i don't seem
to react to unfiltered water
you should probably filter your water
anyway but it doesn't seem to bother me
and skin products don't seem to be
bothering makeup
and things that are injected don't seem
to bother me like i had a really
terrible reaction to a preservative
um sodium metabisulfite which is in a
lot of things
interesting and it was brutal um it was
like soy brutal it was bad
um and they used that in lidocaine
injections
right that's probably what happened to
me because they put lidocaine
in it as well so a lot of places they'll
just put the actual filler in
and do the thing this one because they
were a fancy beverly hills doctor
they put lidocaine in it so that you
don't feel it yeah yeah yeah
and that's what i reacted with wow yeah
that crazy i have a question for you now
okay why do you think we're so sensitive
and
other people in the world aren't so
i actually i've got some theories and i
don't know if any of them are true great
i love those kinds um so what i first
thought was okay what like why do some
people have an autoimmune disorder and
some people don't
like my brother for instance he's fine
and i'm like i'm not anymore but i was
incredibly ill so it's like how do
how do the same parents have kids and
he's born after me so it's not like
something happened to them in between
yeah um
and i think maybe people born through
c-sections
don't inherit part of the microbiome
they're supposed to inherit yes
so i think that's part of the problem
c-sections can contribute
um i think getting hit with antibiotics
when you're young
because i was on a pretty intense dose
under the age of
six months and then i ended up getting a
um
like candida infection right after that
so
there was definitely some dysbiosis
happening pretty quickly
so i think uh overuse of antibiotics and
i've talked to a lot of people with
really severe dietary restrictions and a
lot of them had like they were giving
antibiotics every time they had a cold
that's so bad it's so so i think that's
part of it
um and then i don't do that either
athletes you're going to have to take
antibiotics a lot so just don't do that
like my god all the girls i know who
date athletes have to take a lot of
antibiotics and they get microbiome
problems
yeah saying yeah it's an actual thing it
does lead to dysbiosis
yeah and that's in the literature so
we've got all these [ __ ] that marry
athletes are allergic to gluten for a
reason just saying
okay go like i'm just putting the pieces
together i told you i went faster
keep going yeah so uh i think the diet
has a lot to do with that and you can
see that by like people in the states
because
they're like something like obesity or
certain diseases run in family
families yeah but they can't find a
genetic component and it might be the
actual maybe
buy it how about is butter here's your
genetic component you all eat a lot of
butter
i don't know if it's not not necessarily
butter but butter with the fat with the
sugar wrapped in a flaky
yeah yeah yeah that yeah so but the
weird thing is like when i grew up
we ate my mom was um it turns out she's
celiac as well
so she found out yeah yeah it runs in
families and you can get this anyone
listening you can get tested on 23andme
if you don't want to do the actual
biopsies
and they'll at least rule you out um
but they'll tell you if you have the
gene for it
that's an easy way to test if you'd want
to get biopsies because there's a very
high
false negative for biopsies
um but i think
i don't know i think a lot of it has to
do with microbiome and then if you have
a microbiome
dysbiosis and you end up eating a really
high sugar
diet then that can lead to more
dysbiosis that's interesting oh like all
of that makes sense to me i had
so after the accident i were you
like were you healthy before the
accident was so healthy so you had
zero health problems and then you had
the accident nothing
yeah and i didn't become allergic to
anything
until after the accident okay and there
was an awesome
scientist who actually works for the
company vyam
the microbiome tests uh some people love
them some people don't love them
this scientist was a rock star so she
was dope
she said what were the drugs you were
put on right away after the accident
and within two drugs she goes okay so
this
plus this killed your biome and then
this
did you become allergic to all the
things about it right in there i'm like
yeah it was literally right there
and then they kept throwing drugs at me
so i had the painkillers on top of this
on top of that and then suddenly i was
blowing up when i would have bread
and then suddenly it was the gluten it
was the dairy it was the soy i had no
problems before that
and my mom she had a thyroid
a thyroid surgery but she has some
thyroid stuff going on she started
taking all these pills and then suddenly
she's celiac
and it seems to be there seems to be
like a trigger
for celiac disease is what i'm seeing
and i just kind of see too that there's
like
sensitive people are sensitive period
like you're going to have sensitive skin
maybe sensitive teeth
some sort of stomach maybe oh yeah
issues uh
you might be more sensitive with animals
too and i'm allergic to everything
except for
rabbits really rabbits yeah
wow yeah how did you find like just
rubbed a rabbit on your face
i've repeatedly done those skin tests
yeah like everything's over rabbits
oh i'll get you a rabbit a little bit i
had a rabbit
they don't they're not fun stupid
they're like in pictures they look
really good and they're really
soft but poop machines the little pellet
poop machines yeah yeah yeah and they're
they're gross i got i had a rabbit it
was this big
because all the girls in my class in
grade seven had tiny little bunnies and
i was like
i'm gonna have a giant bunny i'm gonna
have a chance i'm gonna be the king of
grade seven
yeah it was horrible it bit and it
kicked and when you lift it up
under its arms because it weighed like
13 pounds called a flemish giant it
would just swing
to try and get its balance i guess
because it didn't like being picked up
like that and
kick you and his feet were this big see
i have two
rabbit fur coats and
no but i do and i had them before
everyone was really really really upset
about her
and i just really yeah i just think
rabbit i think stew
i think for coat not purchase these
flemish giants are meat rabbits that's
why they're so big
because you can eat them i'd rather eat
it sorry vegans
not sorry vegans you guys are weak you
can't fight me anyway yeah that's that's
how i feel about the vegans they can't
fight me
whatever probably not if it's like oh
they could be a very healthy person
who've just switched to the vegan diet
true i loved hearing miley cyrus talk on
rogan yeah
how she eats meat now again i was like
knew it
yeah mike tyson too really i didn't hear
that no i didn't yeah
he eats me now i kind of said that for
years
i had a video that went like crazy viral
about vegans and
yeah of course he did people got real
mad at it surprised
like how dare you tell the truth flip
table [ __ ] yeah and it's like all right
well a couple years later oh there you
go
okay yeah yeah people who were mad at my
dear fat people video are mostly dead
anyway now so it doesn't even like
[ __ ] it you know like legit so we're
good
bourbon bourbon yeah bourbon break
okay um so you did an alkaline diet
yep you got nerve shots nerve block
injections do them up i've done
everything though
massage therapy bowen therapy do you try
hypnotherapy
i've done hypno i've tried nlp did it do
anything
yeah really did i
didn't the first session because i was
probably fighting it that's what i
figured
um but then by the second if you learn
yeah but i'm still awake like i know
what's going on it's not like i'm just
like ooh
like in a movie yeah yeah yeah i knew
what was going on
and for me it just kind of felt the same
as nlp
and i learned nlp the neuro-linguistic
programming
i am so into that i use that in my
videos yeah
yeah there's really yeah there's like
little triggers
and once you learn them you're kind of
golden and you can
use them in speech with people you can
use them to help program yourself
you can use them to fight pain um
yeah it's that's pretty great i'm not an
expert by any means
but i think everyone should look it up
and if you can go to an nlp session
and you have chronic pain you should do
it test it out yes
interesting i tried hypnotherapy when so
that year
the worst pain i've ever had was the
year before my hip and ankle replacement
it was just brutal and my we were like
desperate
because the opiates too if you're
actually in pain in a lot of
it's not like a wisdom teeth removal
it's like if you're in a lot of pain
then they will or if you've had a
surgery or something they'll numb
your like the reality yeah but they
won't actually get rid of the pain
they just make you care less right yeah
yeah so they just get rid of the caring
yep or like that they just make you
stoned basically
um so i was on opiates and my dad tried
hypnotherapy with me trying to get me to
relax to like
calm down and it was just like but i was
17 too so there's no
first of all there's no relaxing when
you're 17 anyway and i also don't think
your dad could do it too
yeah it was like he was pretty good
but not not biting on his hypnotherapy
skills
however it takes me i'm so scared
to step away i hate i've been to so many
doctors yeah i hate people oh god yeah
people
yeah twitter man [ __ ] people oh my
god some of them though are so nice
and some of them are so cool horrible
but then
no they're just hurt they're just hurt
right they're just like their life sucks
that's sad
yeah yeah and they won't they won't
change it so they yell at you on twitter
yeah
yeah life now i know it's sad listen
your dad i'm sure you're good at
hypnotherapy don't get mad at me
yeah i'm sure you tried real hard you
could do it i'd probably giggle if you
tried because his voice is fun
if my dad tried to hypnothera no my dad
would advertising me no
maybe i'd laugh ah stop it yeah
i feel like i trust him more than most
people though like i've tried to go to
doctors that have suggested things
it's just i don't know i feel like after
you've gone to a num like enough
people i don't know how many specialists
i've been to i stopped going
same my here's here's my thing is that
doctors no offense doctors love you guys
some of you are dope
yeah yeah for pre-requisite okay surgery
surgeons surgeons big fan of the
surgeons and the sturgeons
delicious uh but doctors in general
i'm just like okay well you're just kind
of reading whatever the scientists say
or the scientists decide so why don't i
go straight to the scientists
and that's what i started doing i
started getting my research directly
from the people doing the studies
and i would call them up or i would
message them on instagram or i would
whatever like i just got in contact with
actual scientists
i participated in as many studies as i
could
to do with chronic pain to do with
mental health
to do with uh concussions like i was a
good candidate i've had them all
i'm a collector so they'd put me in
these studies and i would use it to
learn
how they're going to treat us what they
think is going on all of those things so
i was kind of like on the cutting edge
of all of it
and i just went doctors thank you you
implement the things
but the scientists are the ones actually
trying out and learning the things
so i i go to them for my info now i
don't i don't trust
a lot of the doctors either because they
would all tell me i'm not gonna get
better like [ __ ] you
like that's not an answer do your job
you know yeah that's not helpful you
haven't done your job if you're telling
me i'm not gonna get better i know one
of the things that upsets
well i'm probably still resentful about
it it sounds like in your tone yeah yeah
and it's something i should get over
honestly but it's gonna take a while
because i'm like missing two joints and
you can't come back from that right you
can't heal if your joints are gone i'll
get you four joints to make up for it
that would be great there you go extra
leg maybe
um but where was i going with that
you're upset about your joints
the doctor um no it's gone okay
i thought later because that was your
fault though
sorry the remaking she's all that i just
heard about it
yeah i don't think it needs to happen i
don't think we need to remake everything
i don't think i've seen she's all that
you should there's choreographed dancing
by high school students that somehow all
know the routine that's my favorite
like when you watch a high school movie
and everyone knows the routine for no
reason
i didn't really like i didn't watch
movies and
we're very different like normal yeah
why did you do uh i read
gross like you who are you
that was basically i just read until
probably well probably probably until i
was like 25 that's basically what i did
and then
i was also partying like grade 8 on
reading and sleeping okay and suffering
and suffering yeah wow you're so emo
you're like you're like this hot sexy
vampire emo mom
lady with mama's skills and knowledge
and you probably know all the things
from all your yeah because you eat the
meat you probably drink blood at night
not
i don't listen the hollywood people do
you're just like on try now
really yeah they're not just like doing
the prp they're actually drinking it
is that what happens in l.a yeah yeah
they're drinking they're drinking what
is that endocrine no endo
something chrome whatever people are not
healthy asmr
oh my god i'm so in love with your asmr
thanks seriously i've i don't know when
i'm gonna put this out
but i've probably mentioned you in three
of my podcasts now and i've only
released like 20 podcasts so whoa the
ratio is not
looking good but your instagram is so
funny
thanks and it's so positive like you're
i'm glad you get that from it
it is like sweet you go off sometimes on
things that i think deserve
to be gone off on but like
you have this whole go team thing going
on and
that's so nice especially and it's
really nice coming from like
it really bothers me okay i can't wait
there's
i'm glad we talked about some health
stuff anyone who wants to talk to me
about morehouse stuff you can always
message me i'm happy to
but i feel like we're about to go on a
tangent now and yeah we should probably
tangent it
we should like this but i can feel you
on a tangent well i do and i want to
cover the serious stuff because
i can save people especially people who
don't understand that they're allowed to
escape from whatever their hell hell
they're in
yeah so i do touch on that and on like
most of
the i wish i had a bell i would have
rang it yeah yeah i can bring a bell
next time
okay cool um did you do did you do
cheerleading
yeah like are you you're a legit
cheerleader legit cheerleader
yep and then like since grade school
and then high school and then i was on a
team canada all-star team
went to like the world cheerleading
championships like bringing on [ __ ]
damn it was like that's why you've seen
all those movies that i haven't seen
it's in my blood though like that's who
i am as a human my sister
is very different from me and she would
make fun of me but that's literally who
i am and she realized it a couple years
ago she's like oh my god all these years
i made fun of you but like
you weren't acting like that's really
you i'm like yeah this is what i've been
trying to say
my mom kind of did the same thing to me
when i was i was like 18.
and i have an extremely dry sense of
humor so
if i'm joking with someone i generally
i'm not i'm not smiling you're smiling
all the time i'll just say things and
just like wait for a reaction
no no i like smiling or like i can't
help it but she told me when i was 18
and she's like
oh you're joking and it was like it was
probably 12 years of me
saying moment's a joke moment's a joke
after
everything i said wow yeah have you ever
done a personality test
yes like you mean through other people
or through scientology because i've done
both
gosh scientologists are a blast can i
just tell you that
i'm not personally a scientologist but
i've had a great time with them
multiple times and every time like
really
yeah i i think they have a really bad
rap and i don't think it's deserved
really i've never been part of their
personal uh cult as the people who leave
say maybe it's just like every religion
or whatever
some people have a great experience some
people don't i've never met a
scientologist
i don't like do they take all your money
though when you go they haven't asked
for any of my
money and they've been pretty awesome
and i've gone on like
missions with them into really yeah
and i i didn't know at first i thought
it was just like people
and then i showed up and they were all
wearing these yellow jackets that say
scientology i'm like
not in kansas anymore all right well
partying with scientologists today
and we went into the malibu fires to go
rescue
animals and property and all sorts of
stuff a couple years ago and they were
dope
all of them and then you yeah like how
did that it was just
a bunch of scientologists and yellow
jackets and nicole arbour yeah
it really like that was my whole life's
a weird movie
so that happened uh it was carrie casem
i don't know if you know her
she's amazing she's in media she's a
host she hosts a bunch of shows and
radio shows and her dad's
casey kasem like the famous radio host
and
we were chatting and i saw that she was
in the malibu fires rescuing people and
i'm like i can do that
i'm able-bodied i can go help and walk
now
yeah i just i didn't feel right not
helping when like crazy stuff's going
down
so i said yeah pick me up i'm coming and
i got in the car and everyone's in
yellowjackets and we show up to get the
rest of the people and everyone's in the
scientology jackets
and they were like we brought you a
jacket i'm like i'm gonna wear my jacket
but i like your jacket too and then i
spent like
three days with this giant crew of
scientologists helping
three days people yeah and i've done it
multiple times
and i have a bunch of friends who are
scientologists now and i'm like
you're the only religion that it's okay
to talk complete [ __ ] about it and it's
not considered being xenophobic
it's the only one like oh yeah that's
weird yeah if people said the same thing
about muslims they'd be
in big trouble i have a bit of i don't
remember who i was talking to
about this but i've got a bit of a
theory about just religion
is um like there are a lot of people who
don't have they don't feel guilty
right like if you don't help someone who
you should help or you said you were
going to help and you don't then you
don't feel guilty because it's like my
life is about me and not about anybody
else
and i think part of the actors yeah
pretty much right i know some good ones
do you know luke cook
i don't know luke cook i like him okay
maybe he's great i feel like he's a good
person
okay i don't know very many actors i
just mean in general l.a
and i also like i haven't really the
only time i've been in la is like
walking along
like one street for a day it was weird
we were street walking
so it was okay i was walking along a
street nicole okay well i hear the same
thing you just shuffled the words
don't [ __ ] with me i hear you yeah okay
so you were street walking in l.a
it was people there looked different
yeah yeah there were people with like
nose casts
on yep in cafes yeah it's very normal
yeah selfies are a way of life if you
don't know what you look like every five
seconds
do you even look it's like a tree
falling in the woods yeah but everyone's
moving
you said that before we started the
podcast that everyone is moving from la
there's a
mass exodus are they all moving to
austin i hope not i love texas
i lived in texas last year and i [ __ ]
love it and i would love to move back to
texas
were you in austin i was in san antonio
i love it
i'm a texan i i'm a canadian texan in my
heart
like my heart that's that's who i am
like when i got there i was like
my people finally like i wear cowboy
boots all the time anyway
and i love sparkles i love rhinestones i
love cheerleading i love big hair i love
breakfast for dinner i love barbecue i
love southern hospitality i say hi to
people
all day every day people are nice there
i went to
some place that there were just stress
stuffed giraffes everywhere
it was i don't know somewhere in texas
it wasn't austin it wasn't houston it
was like country songs were written
there
it was intense i went to a couple of
rodeos that sounds oh rodeos are so
fun yeah there were children riding
sheep
yeah like three-year-olds yeah you're
welcome you're
holding on imagine that like that's a
lifestyle people cheering you get that
[ __ ] at three years old and you can
perform while riding a sheep you're good
for life
right come on like i just
texas knows what they're doing i think
they're the best people in the world
and then probably mexicans filipinos
below that
and then the chinese like chinese
japanese remix not to
put them in together but like that's my
standings of humans
yeah i don't think i've put standings at
humans russians
it's fun to judge people i'm i'm married
to i'm married to a russian
and eastern europe sorry scared that's
what you would think
see that's how i felt about it for like
four years okay
and russians are they're a weird group
of individuals they're very intense
and women are super mean compared to
canadians okay like eastern european
women
are mean people but if you actually make
friends with them then you have this
kind of bond where they'll do
anything for you like they'll hide
bodies yeah yeah yep and they'll just be
like no problem
don't even don't even mention it we'll
never talk about it again body's gone
it's hidden
figured out because they have other
russian connections let us have some
vodka yeah yeah yep
yeah and you don't get that like i
haven't you don't
get that as much i'm sure you can find
it in north american culture but it's
not it's like
oh well we were friends for 10 years but
like
i've got a thing and yeah i did talk to
this other person about you
and like sorry yeah they're just like
ride or dies
russians yeah it's weird it's like they
hate you and they're mean and
evil and untrustworthy and then you get
in and and it's just like this
wonderful group of individuals that kind
of sounds awesome it is awesome
see i have european eastern european in
me
yeah like the the russian ukrainian
polish oh yeah
i have polish i've pulled you crying in
and then apparently
some of them went out that way but yeah
i see those women and i'm like ah we all
look the same all right yeah yeah
when i went to sweden everyone there
spoke swedish to me because they all
thought i was swedish
so i just had to start learning basic
and then thought yeah have you been to
switzerland
yeah love it i went to zurich and
i've never seen more attractive people
than the people who live in zurich i
thought sweden was more attractive
the guys were all in tights like
yoga pants and you could see everything
all day every day
and like long t-shirts but like with
tights
yeah with tights and they were so hot
and i was just like what are these
humans
all of you need to just procreate all
day like this is
like the world health organization
should force them to procreate just to
make the world better looking
you know i'm not trying to like hitler
it up in like aryan race but like those
are good-looking humans
i felt like that kind of in switzerland
people they were
unbelievably attractive yeah what'd you
do about it i'm just kidding i just like
i i just like stared at people awkwardly
oh yeah
i was walking around ah i don't know
what happened it was like a rough period
of time and i was walking around one of
my shoes was broken i
had flip-flops what happens to you
i didn't say street walk that time okay
walking around walking around
but you know when your flip-flop breaks
and then it doesn't work at all anymore
so i was walking around
with one shoe in zurich which is full of
like
anyone who can afford to live in zurich
okay um
yeah and i went to a store just to buy
these like shitty little flip-flops and
people there were
i was just staring at people wow yeah i
know it was
like wow look at your face it was just
like you could like you could move to
north america and then just make money
on instagram
you don't have to be selling flip-flops
yeah maybe we should they don't know
that though
every corral
of course come on it's business oh my
god that self that's actually a really
good idea
when i had my ankle so i had my ankle
re-repla i told you it was installed
crooked yep
so i did enough research it took like
four years i found
the surgeon who designed the joint and
went to him and was like
what's wrong and he said he held my foot
and went
ah this is not good awesome
and i was right here yeah and he was
like we can
replace one component of it he was still
speaking in a german accent
okay love that accent sound more evil
yeah yeah he wasn't though he was like
yeah we can just replace the top
component and you'll be good and you'll
never have to replace
this is screwed up actually i don't know
if i've talked about this i went to
five surgeons to try and find someone
who could fix my ankle and i went to two
in canada and three in the states and
then i went to the
guy in um just like outside of zurich
and i got different answers from each
surgeon so if you need to have
if you need to have a surgery yeah like
do research because just because you go
to one doesn't mean they act like they
know what they're talking about and i
like surgeons
weird weird category of people but i
like them okay but they don't
necessarily know what they're talking
about so i got these
different answers from each surgeon and
each surgeon in north america said
basically told me i was going to be
[ __ ] by the time i was 40. they're
like we can fix it now but it's going to
wear out
and you'll be screwed by the time you're
40. thanks guys yeah
yeah and i and the last person i went to
said you're looking at an amputation
when you're 40. because you won't have
bone left there
oh god and i went to zurich and he said
we can replace we don't have to replace
the whole joint we can replace the
because it has two components it has
like a bottom part on your foot and a
top part yeah on your leg
and he's like the only part that's
crooked is the top part we can just
replace the top part and you'll be good
forever
and i was like okay yeah that sounds
better than the amputation option
and i went there and that's a lot easier
like you're done
yeah yeah and i get it he's lazy yeah
chop it off
yeah i get it yeah okay amputation don't
steal your thought oh my god you you
will
um anyway even the x-ray technicians
there were cute
it was like cute like it was weird man
it was weird
[Music]
yeah they weren't trying either they
were just cute i heard it was because
i don't know how this makes sense at all
but like vikings
stole all the attractive women from
different areas and just like put them
all in the same spot
yeah yep i've heard that too i know that
i know for a fact that i'm a descendant
of vikings and it makes so much sense
for my life
yeah i'm just like let's go you've got
norwegian in you
yeah i've got norwegian in me too holler
yeah
how do you know we should start a trend
i don't know i remember
someone told me a long time ago see
we're doing asmr
and then someone told me a long time ago
and they did
like the family history kinds of things
the funniest [ __ ] is if you see what my
family crest is and what it means it's
at my uncle's house
and it's basically saying that we are
the inevitable lifelong court jesters
like that's what my family line is we
have always
been basically like we're cool with
royalty and we always have been or we
have been
royalty because we're funny and quick
and witty and get along with
lots of people is that running your what
about you you talked about your sister
though you said your sister isn't like
family's funny
like my uncles if you get my dad and my
uncles in the same room it's like
watching a tv show like a sitcom
that has been written and you're just
like i'm the least funny of all these
people
like 100 but they're so quick it's like
growing up with jabs
constantly so you just have to go fast
you can't get in the combo yeah
it's fun growing up with my dad was a
little bit like that yeah he'll just
talk over everybody so you have to like
learn
jump in squish your way in yeah there's
like slight pauses you learn
too you'll know the time but if you get
someone who doesn't know like
no offense to my husband but like
russian didn't grow up with the same
like really fast
back and forth yeah yeah and he had no
idea how to cut in
oh people can't believe that's just like
i'm so bored it's just like there's like
a half a sentence and
like trying to get in it's like stop
stop don't you like you gotta jump in
there's like a
half second pause here that's when you
make your entry yeah you talk a little
bit loud so that people
you gotta shock him because if you don't
surprise someone with his brain of what
i've seen
then it won't give him a second to go
wait what and then you have that second
yeah to go
that's a good game it's a good game it's
cutting it it's good game fun finding
those people
yeah yeah yeah that must have been a fun
way to grow up
yeah amongst all the lenin paintings it
wasn't that bad amongst your what
lenin paintings okay that's weird it was
weird
that's weird i didn't know it was weird
either was it like did you grow up in a
weird house
or where was it not weird the house was
really
normal like the house was very quite
normal my mom's decorating skills as the
years went on got weird
because she'd get things like a giant um
tiger head
like it's like it's an art piece and
she's like this goes on the mantel i'm
like does it
i do that does that go on the mantel
yeah so we're in like the nice
white and bright and then there's a
tiger head and i'm like yeah mom
yeah see okay if that's your decorating
skills that's cool i would do that
i'm not a i'm not a tiger head on the
mantel you can see my
logo i love that logo it kind of looks
like it just did its hair and it's
wearing a bow tie or no
a normal tie it's a normal time i like
it
thank you you're welcome we're almost
done this
i think it's making us better it's
definitely improving my life
i don't know what's making me better do
you wanna know a story i'm gonna tell
you a story
i'm just kind of asking to be polite
no that's why you're here i wanna hear
stories uh the beginning of podcast is
always my least favorite because i kind
of hate talking about myself
like i know my story and i know that my
stories
help people but i always feel like a
douche retelling my stories because i'm
like
you know well you've told it 10 000
times i
i kind of have the same thing that's i
like i've got this weird love-hate
relationship with podcasting because
if i go on somebody else's podcast yep
it's really easy
because if there's a pause then they ask
me a question and like i know my story i
can retell it
yep and it does get repetitive but i
know it helps people i can do that but
yeah when i'm running the podcast and
then i have to think of things to say
jesus i had a couple of people on i
haven't released these yet but i had
navy seals on duh i know but
i don't usually get nervous around
people
and i'm so i'm not used to what that
feels like
right so i was talking to jocko willink
jocko's dope yeah yeah but literally i
was sitting there
i don't know when i'm going to release
this like figure out the order of
releasing podcasts but i was like
talking to him
and thinking like okay mikhail you just
have to like remember
to respond to what he's saying you know
how to have a conversation you know how
to talk just to
just respond to whatever he says just
like have a conversation
that's what i was like i have this
opportunity to talk to jocko wellington
like just remember how to respond
that's really funny and it's really
funny because i have no
problem i have no problem presenting in
front of people yeah like i can do a
full presentation
i can have conversations with tons of
people but like
navy seals that's who you fangirl over
i think it might be bad over navy seals
isn't that interesting to figure out
i don't fangirl over bands or any of
that kind of i've never have not
i don't have the problem with like
actors musicians for you guys
i love talking to comedians like like
that banter is really easy but like
i don't know navy seals was just like
just like freaking me out
they're fun psychologically they're
they're a different breed
i like that breed yeah i get along with
that's kind of what reminds me of
russians hmm
yeah it's the same thing but they're
like emotionless
kinda but funny no
which ones russians aren't funny oh man
not really they don't have the same kind
of like funny they don't have the same
kind of humor like british humor they
have this dry
sarcasm that's like that seems very you
yeah and i i love that and yeah and with
it like i didn't
vibe well like that with russians
they're very like
what do they laugh at other people dying
like what are they what do they laugh at
well if i like take examples from my
husband it's just
yeah kind of that yeah like bad bad like
dark
jokes that bad things happening to other
people or other countries if you will
kind of or or um those really
like simple they're simpler jokes yeah
and that's not an insult to them because
i
love them i love russian says yeah their
women are so mean but like
yeah you keep saying it and i believe
you they are it's true
um i'm like i'm a bit traumatized from
my experience in moscow but
are you okay oh yeah man i have survived
way worse than
what kind of mean have you though mean
girls are hard that's hard to get
through
no i've survived worse for sure okay
fair what are they like
yeah they're just like have you seen
okay
okay have you seen there's this tv show
right now it's called
sunset valley there's what's up
boulevard selling sunset yes selling
that one
yes okay christine yep
is like a soft russian woman a soft
russian okay yeah i totally get it
yeah so russian women they're just like
they're just mean it's a very
dominance oriented culture compared to
like in north america everyone's nice to
each other
depends on the person but most people
are just nice to each other yeah and in
russia they don't care about
any of that and they're just like like
what's your job how much money do you
make what do you look like
and they just judge you based on that
and if you're above them they're nice to
you and if you're below them they're
just like
i think you could like trump card that
by just not talking
you can i i learned this so i used to
like i'd go over there and say spasiba
to like everything because i'm canadian
yeah like thank you
and people would like waiters would just
look at me like i had a third eye
and then i started being a [ __ ] and
then i got respected more
so this whole like being polite thing is
definitely i don't know if it's american
you've lived in l.a what are people in
l.a like they're [ __ ] they're
self-obsessed [ __ ]
they say thank you no do they open doors
for people
not a lot i've been at a coffee shop
like
it actually like hurts my soul a bit
that's why i love texas but like hurts
my soul a bit when
i'm at a coffee shop and someone will be
like all right uh yeah
give me this this this this and this
yeah okay thanks
no they don't say thanks my bad yeah
blah blah blah yeah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah
blah blah i'm like okay he meant to say
thank you like i'll say that
i'll be like you meant to say thank you
right he totally meant to say thank you
yeah
like the canadian thing though it's
gross though not to say thank you or
please
it's gross i think it's gross because
that's a human they they might make
minimum wage
like i'm i'm not a very nice per like
i'm
like right away i was like what a sea
unit you know like when i met you i saw
your face i'm like
oh yeah gross this [ __ ] is a this [ __ ]
is a mean person
this is a [ __ ] i'm nice to people who
aren't
like fake nice uh yeah but like
plain courtesy saying thank you to
people
just like how many people have worked as
waiters like most
most people i worked as a waiter yeah
loved it
it was fun mind you i was at hooters
so like everyone was really nice to me
and i got paid to hula hoop out front
yeah it was a it actually like
skyrocketed my career actually working
there
working at hooters working at hooters
was probably it was my tv debut do you
want this story
do you want the hooters story are you
kidding me
okay so i had i told you i'd been
a raptors girl a bud light girl or a bud
girl
coors light girl i've been like all
these girl things
how did you get into that can we diverge
we can do that for a second how did you
even like how did that happen
i see something i'm like okay i want to
do that and then i go but like so
i had been a dancer my whole life i saw
raptors girls like i was at one of the
first games when i was like
10 or younger one of the first raptors
games and i was like i would be one of
their cheerleaders that's amazing look
at these girls dancing they're so good
so then i just waited for the auditions
and i when i was old enough and then i
went
and then i eventually made it and then
okay i'm a raptors girl
and then bud light i found through a
promo company through this
okay that's how you become a bud girl
these girls are the ones running these
promos
i did that and it was it was a good job
it was such a good job you're like
21 and making 20 to 40 an hour that's
awesome
yeah that's good yeah and you're just
wearing a cute top and taking photos
with people and talking to people it was
it was the best you learned so much
about people and about men
men skills uh yeah so i just kept doing
all these different things
and then i realized the one thing i
hadn't done
is be a hooters girl like on that list
of girl things and
like how do you go from raptor to
raptors to hooters
well i literally like i'm just silly and
i'm like okay
who does girl just want to experience it
i literally drove by and i'm like
hooters girl
that's the one i haven't been when i
sell it to my friends i'm like i gotta
be a hooter girl at least for a couple
days
then i could check it off the list i've
been all the girls i'm a girl and that
you had a woman britney spears
and then i walked in and i told the
manager ass to the manager and i was
like hey
i gotta work here for a couple days i
know it sounds funny but i need to check
this on my list
this is my girl bucket list and this
seems to be the only thing i'm missing
and he was like you're weird and i was
like you're correct
he's like okay come downstairs uh have
you served before i'm like nope
he's like can you do any of these other
things i'm like not at all
he's like are you with people i'm like
probably i told him i'm a comic whatever
hired me on the spot started the next
day um
it was so much fun i had this
preconceived notion that hooters was in
line with stripping
like i thought it was like i thought it
was like a strip club where the guys
were just gross and whatever
it wasn't it was slinging wings it was
so much fun
and families go there families go there
during lunchtime
good wings yeah oh there's butter in the
sauce and it's delicious
yeah so they were there i had a great
time i made so much money
and then from the hooters from hooters
from tips
tips yeah couple you know a couple
monday night footballs
you're you're good i was making way more
as a hooters girl than a raptors girl
let me tell you i would say like
20 times no way yeah
yeah like a hundred percent and
it was it was a lot of fun so i'd be
like hula hooping out front and serving
wings and
talking with people talking to people is
my favorite thing in the whole world
because i already know what i know
that's why i find myself boring on
podcasts i'm like oh i've already heard
this story as i say it
but yeah life you know but i get to talk
to new people all day
that's the [ __ ] best you learn from
people all day
and then one day i had this guy come in
by himself and he's eating wings and
watching sports
and he's i'm chatting him up like just
shooting the [ __ ] and i start making fun
of the blue jays because i knew a couple
guys on the team at the time
and my one buddy at the time alex rios
he always choked up he wouldn't choke up
on his bat he was
holding it really freaking weird no he
choked up too high and i was like dude
what are you doing and i started like
yelling at the screen making fun of him
and the guy's like wait what'd you just
say
and i made fun of him again and he's
like how did you know that and the next
guy comes up and i made fun of his stats
and whatever he's like
what do you do who are you you're not a
hooters girl
and i was like i'm a comic i do this and
this but listen i have a list and i have
to check it off the list
and i told him the spiel and he's like
do you want to be on tsn
i think you should be on tsm really yeah
a random tsm guy came in
this was a guy who was from the fan 590
who
made a call to tsn right there and i was
on
um off the record the next day so a tsn
sport show where there's like a panel
and it literally went like that like
that work
yeah like canada sports network yeah
yeah yeah so it's like our version of
espn so i was suddenly on our version of
espn
on our sports panel talk show the next
day
and then i was on that show like 10
different times and then suddenly i got
picked up by much music
which was our version of mtv in canada
yeah and it didn't matter that i was a
comedian all my friends were comics
trying to get on
much music i got it because i was on tsn
because i was a hooters girl
not because i had done all these clubs
not because i'd done all these other
things it's cause i was good at talking
[ __ ] about sports
on tsn and that's how it happened and
then
hooters though is because you can you
know how to jump on opportunity and you
just say yes to everything right
yeah i say i say yes to stuff but i also
went i was true to myself and i went
with my stupid list
and i worked so then the opportunity
found me
because i followed my intuition well
i really like it was fun yeah i know
that sounds great and
man like although no i feel like i don't
know
i like what's it like censoring yourself
in real time
that must be like being constipated
censoring myself in real time yeah
i don't you maybe one of the times you
hit your head yeah just deleted that
i've heard that or were you always like
this i was like serious questions i feel
like i was like that
and then i didn't get like that because
i was conditioned by society not to be
like that anymore
and then i hit my head and i didn't
listen first all that
this is what happened to me i was on
ssris from the age of 12 till 23.
okay and a very high dose and it
completely got rid of all my social
anxiety 100
nice yeah but like to uh like
like to a degree that i don't think is
socially acceptable in a
like positive way okay fair like so it
like i think
it just deleted that part of my brain um
and then i stopped taking ssris and i've
been taking them since i was 12.
so like that's gonna i feel like that
will affect your development a bit
i'm nodding but i don't know what an
ssri is celexa citalopram
it's just an antidepressant okay um
and then when i stopped taking them i
had social anxiety for the first time in
my entire life
and social have you had social anxiety
yeah i think it's normal
see i'd never experienced that until i
was like 23 and it was like
i started hearing my thoughts before i
started speaking them that weird
isn't that weird we're not supposed to
do that i don't think we're supposed to
do it i don't think we're supposed to do
that that's
social conditioning it's hor i don't
think it's social conditioning i think
it's
diet or something maybe because i like i
never had it
and then i had it i don't really have it
anymore but i had to like
learn kind of to get over it and
i'll talk to myself in my own head no
that's horrible though no but i'll be
like hey
you i just heard you say that
we're not actually scared you're scared
because you've heard someone that we're
supposed to be scared about this
this is fun for me so you're gonna have
to shut the [ __ ] up because we're gonna
do this anyway actually
like you fight it yeah i like i legit
fight it like i remember
before going on stage doing like a i
think like a 15-minute stand-up set like
a special thing
and there's i don't know like three to
five thousand people in that crowd
and intense yeah i've done up to
what i do probably up to twenty thousand
people in a crowd like music festival
yeah and it's super cool and how do you
see them or are the lights too bright
no i can see them if it's daytime and
you're at a music festival
you can see them is that the best high
ever though it's really fun
because i like making their day that's
what like makes me so happy i'm like
yeah we're
we're having fun yeah it's fun
uh but yeah i got nervous
because someone else told me
you get nervous i didn't naturally get
nervous
i naturally get excited and i'm sure
that you know like being excited and
being nervous are
very similar and what they are same kind
of heart thing
physiologically psychologically they're
the same [ __ ]
so you get to decide if you're nervous
or if you're excited and
i i remember feeling nervous and i was
only nervous because there's all these
cameras around me backstage and people
are pacing and i'm like
wait no i'm not nervous this is fun for
me be you
what are you doing trying to take in
this stupid energy
and then i did it i um i watched a video
i think and
i don't know i was watching a video on
panic attacks and how to manage panic
attacks
and this woman and i don't know if i buy
this to be completely honest but
her suggestion was if you're
experiencing a panic attack which is
like a physiological
your heart beats faster you can be
sweating and things
try and start thinking about something
that excites you
and try and kind of like switch your
mind over wonder whatever
you're freaking out to something that's
exciting and then your body can calm
down
i'm not sure if i buy that but it is a
very similar feeling
interesting i have yeah it sounds it
sounds like it won't work though
i have weird feelings about things like
panic attacks
and even depression have you had panic
attacks tons
like tons have you ever had tunnel
vision yes oh my god isn't it intense
it's weird it's very right i kind of
feel lucky that i've had all this
crazy [ __ ] up stuff happen like i'm
like i'm kind of like
like not in the moment now that you're
drinking bourbon
yeah i can bourbon it's a bourbon friday
oh look you're getting cheery yes yes
this
is two more of these um you got a
different girl
uh yeah but i have different thoughts on
panic attacks and anxiety attacks and
why people have anxiety
and all of these things and i realize
that my thoughts on it are controversial
but
frankly i [ __ ] help people so take my
words or don't well also like
you can control it you need to put the
information out there yeah
as long as it's out there yeah because
people can listen to whoever they want
to but
like whoever needs to listen to people
panic attacks are brutal yeah like they
make people suicidal they're horrible
to experience so like even if whatever
you're saying is wrong
people can listen to somebody else
what's the stupidest song you've ever
heard
wow that is so random no it's not trust
what's the stupidest song you've ever
heard
i'm i'm saying this because i
have discovered that you can do a
pattern interruption and if you're
having a panic attack
which happens if you have in your mind
that you're gonna
intercept your panic attack attacked
attack you can do it you can do it and
that's what i started doing is i started
fighting my own depression
and i would literally meet it in the
ring in my mind
and i would be like yo depression we're
not [ __ ] doing this
i'm stronger than you so you separated
the voices in your head
separate the voices in your head so if
you're having a panic attack and there's
a song
that you were like this is the dumbest
[ __ ] song i've ever heard
i hate this or i love it either way gets
stuck in my head
and every time you have a panic attack
you have that song
cued up in your own head that you're
what is it
do you have one or no it might be the
mississippi squirrel
revival oh play it please for just one
second
you can do up to 30 seconds and then no
one gets mad at you on the internet
oh yeah yep it's bad these are okay i
can't wait
i shall drink from my straw i need to
skip to a good part
oh yeah
listen i've never heard that song in my
life
you should have there's there's another
squirrel song that that that was
actually like
that's among there with the whole
squirrel songs that i think are
ridiculous oh you have a whole genre of
squirrely songs
yeah like i lost a lot of country as a
child okay
like bad country too okay country not
just johnny cash and
hank williams like like country country
yeah
yeah intense american country that it's
kind of fun
oh it's so much more fun and what's
going on now yeah
it's i just want to listen to squirrel
now
imagine with me if you will your full
panic attack
it might happen chances are you might
have another panic attack in your life
i have now planted a seed in your mind
that the next time you have a panic
attack
you're gonna think of that [ __ ]
squirrel song and you're probably gonna
laugh
and you're probably thinking my stupid
voice right now slightly slurring from
having some
bourbon and it's gonna take you out of
that moment for a second where you're
having a panic attack is that like
honestly though
honestly yeah i've had so i have my
mental health and
so i was diagnosed with bipolar type 2
okay which is just like
severe depression with like hypomanic
episodes which are the good part okay
what's your creative outlet though
i used to draw i write what do you still
do
if if you're a bipolar of any sort and
you don't have an extreme creative
outlet and physical cod
i know this year has been rough but i've
managed to keep
it under control with diet okay like
it's under control with diet so
it's not there anymore um but you can
stress people who are
still stable out to a degree where they
still experience panic cool
if like you're having a bad time um
so i don't i don't know i like i've had
a couple of panic attacks and i'm at
least
well versed in mental health enough that
i'm like oh
i am experiencing a panic attack like
this will end just like
this physiological reaction that happens
and it goes away
yep so i've managed to control it but i
haven't really i feel like i'm pretty in
control of
trying to calm down and trying to focus
on other things and i haven't managed to
get
those under control doing anything other
than just waiting
hmm yeah like it works i had one earlier
this year january
and it was because my dad was not well
yeah and so it was like family health
yep and that's
[ __ ] like i was sick my entire life and
family health it's so much harder
dealing with somebody else being sick
yep because there's so much less control
mm-hmm like at least if it's you
then you're like i got this i'm like or
like i'm [ __ ] but like
i know where i'm at yeah um and there
was like
it was just like a physiological
reaction and then it ended
um but you have things that cause i i
never experienced panic attacks
you need to cut it yeah that's a song as
well uh
yeah you can cut it and i would have
tons of panic attacks
i would get suicidal i would was this
when you were in pain though
yeah okay in a lot of pain or even like
panic attacks i had panic attacks during
corona when i was by myself for multiple
months
by myself people are i okay
i got demonetized from youtube which is
fine why
i'm not sure they didn't tell me okay
but i'm demonetized which is like
that's okay because i'm fortunate enough
to have other sources yes
i don't need to survive yeah yeah yeah
so i don't need it but like it pisses me
off because they didn't
tell me why and other people in the same
situation who might be relying on
ads yeah they're cowards like that
totally yeah it's like at least tell
people like have some sort of
anyway so just yeah it doesn't really
bother me
but i don't know where i'm going with
that again
you're going youtube and demonetized and
we're talking about mental health
rhinovirus
coronavirus people aren't looking at the
other effects that
being in lockdown like cause like we
don't even know what it's going to do to
[ __ ] kids
or paranoid like my poor three-year-old
and we're not even that we were pretty
paranoid in march to be fair
because we didn't know what kind of
virus we were dealing with uh-huh uh
she's like washing her hands all the
time oh it was like i don't want to like
breed a neurotic child
yeah and then if you look at i looked at
i mean i've met you you're probably
gonna i'm just kidding
i'm just teasing you okay that's your
laugh when you're like you're probably
gonna ha ha
forgive me but like also
it's funny i mean it a little bit no
that's funny like realistically it it
might happen i'm trying really hard not
to
she'll be really smart so with smart
comes some sort of
hopefully smart hopefully cute and yeah
you're gonna be
like crazy like you sounded like they
cake it was so healthy
it was it was a i know and that's what
i'm saying that's like verging unhealthy
in my eyes
wow like there's a lot of [ __ ] sugar
in a watermelon yeah it's true
okay nicole yeah where can people find
you online
all of the interwebs instagram i'm
letter i letter b
nicole arbour and why why don't you just
have nicole arbour um
there is a woman named nicole arbor who
stole it from me and she asked you for
like ten thousand dollars
she asked me for a lot more than that
and out of principal i made
ib and equal arbor because i be nicole
arbor
and yeah on facebook nicole arbour fans
just my regular name
twitter nicole arbour because i beat her
to that [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] she [ __ ] up there
right she [ __ ] up there
yeah and uh yeah those are like my main
three youtube same
but yeah no i will not pay someone for
my name i won't do it
yeah so thank you very much for coming
on this has been very fun
thank you for having me go team i can't
wait to have you on my show and thank
you for the lipstick
yeah this is amazing yeah you like it
how do you feel
good hopefully it doesn't rub off on my
mask yeah we'll see you let me know
i will love it thank you nicole
[Music]
you